请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
各位晚安 各位晚安
有听到声音吗
有听到声音 价格一啊
有听到声音 让我知道
你有聽到聲音
有聽到聲音
加個1
好
有聽到
加個1
好
我們要來講這個
揭秘增大戶少貨清單
那最近呢
最近各位那個
這個大盤實在是
這個我們講世紀投資法裡面
大盤是純純的夏天啊
純純的夏天
各位你看一下
超级蠢的 夏天
那夏天呢就怎么样
夏天就是找机会做多啊
而且他现在是开布林延上轨 主力买
我的大盘的多单都不敢卖
都不敢卖 因为我有一些股票的空单
所以我必须要利用大盘的多单来保护我
那我也有一些股票的多单
有一些股票多单 最近表现也
也还不错 首先来看一下
這個今天表現應該算還不錯的
看一下華泰
哦 華泰今天大漲了
那華泰呢他是有這個
他是有
呃 那個
全證的分點大買
哦 那雖然表現的是有點弱啦
但是這個全證分點呢我覺得
呃 我覺得他蠻厲害的
哦 所以呢 後面
我不知道他有沒有機會啦
哦 感覺起來應該是有機會
哦 那華泰呢
这边嗯他还有期货啊所以华太我有买期货我目前目前转仓之后是获利的我来找一下找一下华泰
各位看一下
华泰这个分点是厉害的
台中哥哦
这个是华人永昌台中哥
卖华泰
买在这边这边这边
都买啊
那今天有稍微
稍微表态一下
其实还不错啦
目前为止他还是赔钱的
那华人永昌台中算是厉害的分点
分點哦那
這個
嗯雖然大買還是賠錢的我
我看好他啦
看好他所以各位你可以觀察一下看
華泰是不是一個不錯的標的
然後呢
最近有些開布林岩上軌的
像例如說像中宮
中宮這種開布林岩上軌主力買
這就是一個非常強勢的症狀
那最近他也有一些新聞
新闻啊
各位你可以看一下新闻啊
这边有什么保家中工
金银权开打
通常这个
都是一个
都是通常我们在三月份的时候
我们最喜欢开打好不好
特别热爱他开打
巴不得他不打
因为这种通常金银权开打
要么就是
要去抢票了嘛
现在他要去抢票
那抢票呢
就是到后来会有两种状况啊
一就是拿到选票嘛
二就是拿到钞票
一拿到选票
二拿到钞票
目前为止感觉还在
还在这个
还在拼命拿选票中
所以你看
中公提告控三家委托通路业者
违反证券交易法
什么意思
就是那个怕票被人家抢走啦
所以呢就开始这个
在动作
所以我们还蛮喜欢怎么样
蛮喜欢在抢票的好
这个是中国目前的状况
开布林严上尾
开布林严上尾主力买
这看起来
好像好像有人在收
也不知道谁在收
反正就是高盛收大摩收新加坡瑞州
现在那个假外资太多了
所以我也不晓得他到底是不是真外资
我不知道是不是真外资
搞不好是有人混进去
然后变成假外资
就这样子
好
那
这个
哦有人讲永贯永贯我解释一下
因为我担心
因为这个我们讲一下永贯的事件
永贯的事件是这样子的这个永贯呢呃事实上我一开始哎这个各位你知道我是用心经赚买的吗哦那心转呢他有先给我们
给我们钱哦
那我就想说哎他已经那个啊
他已经他已经拿到钱了吗
哦结果心算是先给我们
哦那所以呢
我就写说啊卖回日快到了
各位记得去卖回
因为你这不卖回
年后的价格会变很差哦
所以我们是跟人家讲说
你要记得去卖回啊
因为你不卖回
那后面是100块
那这当然是会变差啊
那我也不希望有人因为这个
这个文章看到而去跑跑去买永冠吗
所以永冠出事的当然是哎
哇你看到永冠是看到
看着欧眼就开钱
你看到哎
小哥讲永冠是好像在讲他很好
跑去买哦那那不就衰了
哦那他出事的时候我们是讲说
你要记得要卖回
那你看永冠叠成这样
他的可转载还是文不上这都是
以
已知的消息这已知的哦有没有看到
这都已知的吗
这全部都已知的而且都是
过去曾经有的
好
结局要汇到多少钱都写给你会到多少钱都写给你
因为那时候是20
2026年2月20号都写给你了吗
除了公司倒哎
现在出现了啊
除了公司倒
那现在他就面临的
他现在
再还不出来还不出来
就两种状况嘛
一嘛就是要还钱
所以呢他现在有三个月的时间要还钱
一要还钱
二呢怎么样
你真的还不出来就宣报倒闭吧
所以我说除了公司倒以外没有钱
没有错啊就是要嘛倒嘛
没有倒他就要给钱
所以呢这全部都没错
但是我不希望有人看到这个
看到我贴他就跑去买
我是2月12号贴的
各位你要看这日子哦
我没有叫你买哦
2月12号已经封关了
因为2月12号我就拿到钱了
因为这是新赚嘛
新赚拿到钱
好这个2月12号贴的
我不是叫你去买这一档
就是叫你说你有卖回
因为2月12号13号还可以卖回
所以我是提醒人说
你有卖回的你记得要去卖回
因为12 13号是可以卖回的
12 13号是可以卖回的哦
可以卖回的哦
他自让到13号都可以卖回
那因为他这次的市值太低了所以太多人卖回那太多人卖回那他一时筹不出来那就是公司的事情了所以我们不是叫你去买是叫你说你要实行你的卖回权
各位呢你要记得这事情
那星星赚跟这个
跟投资人的关系啊
这个以后有机会再跟各位讲了
那我觉得其实大家玩这个就知道
你买可转载
你就是有可能遇到违约的风险
你有可能遇到违约的风险
所以你要做事怎么样
你要做事要分散
好啦 那跟各位讲
假设这档真的出事了
那其实
在经由长时间的买可转在过程中
他当然会影响到我的获利啊
当然会影响到
那也不至于说让我变成大赔啊
也没有
我就这样子
这个只能跟各位讲
永贯目前是这样
那我不希望投资人一看到
一看到
小哥叫人家鼓吹人家买勇冠
没有 各位
这文章从头到尾
都没有叫你买勇冠
各位看清楚
没有叫你买勇冠
我只跟你讲说
那个你要记得要去迈回
那大部分的可转载
目前来讲大概200档
200档可转载里面
可能有一档不还钱
那大部分的可转载呢
就是几月几号到多少钱都写给你
所以这边写的全部都没有问题
你懂什么
啊这个本来就是会有倒的风险啊
那倒的风险
那你要怪我说我鼓吹你买永冠
我没有鼓吹你买永冠啊
我们以前这个没有鼓吹你买永冠
是跟你讲说
你真的要买可转载
你又
你又不希望这个万一倒闭的话
其实我们有一个方法啦
就是说
那我也可以在这边跟各位讲
有一个方法
这个我们在上课都有提到说
你真的要买可转债
然后你又怕它倒
有方法就是你负债比找低一点
负债比找低一点
然后呢速动比找大一点
然后呢
KY比较麻烦
那KY比较麻烦
因为KY就是
它的财报不见得是很透明
所以你可以放弃KY
那不然找负债比低一点
那速动比大一点
那像永冠他就没有符合我们的那个要求吗
那虽然没有符合要求
所以没有符合我的要求
我的风货就是我买少一点
我买少一点
所以呢
我没有办法说
这个没有符合
应该说没有符合要求
我就买少一点
但是我在教学上
我们都说你可以找负债比低一点
然后速冻比大一点
例如说像红帆
就还不错啦
这负债比52
我们是希望小于50
但目前小于50的就可能就红郁
那速冻比大100
我们只能这样子讲
说你要比较安全的就这样子
那你要刺激一点的
当然当然有可能会出事了
啊这没办法这个在市场上就这样
你要你要投报率好一点
有可能就是会面临比较大的风险
那我控制我的风险就是我的标的分散
那我标的分散
那假如这场真的是出事啊
假设后来他倒了什么
那刚好呢
我的这个赔钱的还可以拿来做教材
那我还可以跟各位讲说
那个赔钱的过程我们要怎么办
所以我们教学就这样
赚钱的也教你 赔钱的也教你
赔钱的过程跟各位讲
我跟各位讲 热身我也有啊
那个时候我们上次在
以前在讲可转载的时候
在讲可转载的时候
我也跟学生讲我有热身啊
因为这个热身一定要参与的嘛
热身看起来会出事
所以当时呢 我买两张热身
然后呢 两个户头
两个户头呢 然后去参与收购嘛
两个户头参与收购
然后呢我还去空三张
空三张热身然后买两张
后来参与嘛
后来我有拿到
实际上我觉得最
有拿到钱就是中国信托那一笔而已
有拿到钱就是中国信托那一笔
后面还是没有拿到
热身就这样
热身后面因为有农券的关系
所以也没有赔到多少钱
应该也算没赔到
所以呢就这样
所以那整个过程
所以我们教学现在是
赚钱的也遇到了赔钱遇到了
哦这个
可转贷已经很多年没出事了很多年
可转贷大概有
5年没出事了5年
好那你想看一年发可转贷有几档
所以你看看这个一年发可转贷有几档啊5年没出事
你看看转贷这么多档
这么多档哦
然后5年没出事了
那咬永贯这次
我不晓得会不会出事啊不知道反正呢 这三个月才知道哦 那所以呢一开始我们当然是希望投资人不要跨点欧阳的开钱看到小哥叫你买你就买
我也没叫你买
这个文章
原本的文章就这样
这边的文字没有改
那我后面呢再补一个
就这样出事
我是不希望有人看到就买
因为出事了总是不需要你买嘛
那
那有的人为什么
因为
這個目前還可以交易你知道嗎
這個永冠市目前是可以交易的
各位看一下
今天他還可以交易喔
那我們建議人家是怎麼樣
各位你看這個偉賣90嗎
我們建議人家是什麼
你要實施賣回啊
各位有沒有看到
你要記得去賣回
不然年後的價格會變很差啊
有沒有看到
不然年後價格變很差
各位你有沒有看到這個
我寫這個
那你觉得我整篇 我有没有鼓吹你去买
我假如鼓吹你去买 我三文 那就怪怪的
那我也不是三文
我们没有三文 我们是让你说
因为不希望有人看到嘛 所以没有三文
三文你根本也看不到这篇文这样
所以我们只是让你 因为我不晓得
我不晓得会不会有人看到就跑去买
你懂吗
要怎么卖回 你要去找你的
你的那个
你的营业员
来不及了
各位 下一麦回呢 只剩下
2028年的2月20号
只剩下这个而已
哦 这个 已经
那个 2026年2月20号已经过了
好 就这样子啊
所以整个故事就这样
所以这个
第一个 没有鼓吹人家叫你买
因为你自己看嘛 2月12号发的
2月12號當然不會鼓吹你買
要鼓吹你買早就鼓吹你買了
然後你買了這個鼓吹你買我好出貨
對不對 假如要真的要這樣玩的話
我們根本沒有 我們是2月12號封關之後
封關之後 所以各位懂了嗎
所以我們完全沒有任何想要坑殺投資人的意思
只是跟你講說 這個大部分的可轉載
是這種結果就是
股价虽然跌了
但是大部分的公司是会认账的
那永万不认我就没办法了
你懂吗所以我们讲说你还是有个风险就是除了公司倒所以呢 他假如真的不还款 他就得倒因为你不倒
你又不还钱 又不倒
这个说不过去啦 说不过去
因为就是 你就得清算给人家嘛
所以这个是 这样比较好
可转载 连跑都没机会好一次次
真的会比较好吗
这个 200档你会遇到一档
就这样子
200一党会遇到一党是这样子
那可观点战权人可以提好书位
没错啊
他本来就可以提好书位
他有一个2026年的最后迈回日
那大部分的可转在最后迈回日都没出事
就这党有出事
就这样子
那遇到就遇到啦
遇到我们就是坦然面对啦
不然怎么办
你还是会遇到啊
对这个江湖走跳你总不能老是说
对你总不能说
那个每次出事的我都没有
不可能嘛因为我们的标的这么分散
我们可转载就是分散嘛
因为分散就是
分散就是可以降低风险
那选择有关
其实不是不是特别喜欢有关
其实永住安还有做风控
特别不要买那么多
不是特别喜欢有关
是把那个 呃这个有殖利率的
这个就是有道歧殖利率的
大部分都有买
然后大部分都有买
那有些比较有问题的就买少一点
就这样子
所以呢会不会遇到出事
当然还是会遇到出事啊
那会不会遇到没事
当然大部分都没事啊
对吧我们大部分都遇到没事嘛
那我们在教学上也不会叫你去买泳冠
会跟你讲说啊你真的要买
你要去買那個比較安全的啦
所以我們是
跟各位講比較安全的買法
啊然後呢
我們自己去買比較刺激的嘛
你懂我意思嗎
就像
就像那個
這個教滑雪的
一定跟你講說
你這個這邊滑比較安全
教你滑雪比較安全
我們滑雪教練就開始
滑那個很危險的嘛
啊大部分都這樣子
所以
沒辦法
遇到就遇到
我也沒辦法
啊 賠就賠
其實康爾星星傳
他覺得 他也說 我也蠻
這個蠻似大體 我們也沒有說硬拗什麼 也沒有啊賠就賠啊啊 就是只只是希望因為目前的目前的債權喔因為康爾是康爾戶頭他是債權人啊
我們不是債權人
我們是衍生性商品的持有人
那這一端集已經結算了
但是未來遇到事情
我們還是會去面對啦
啊 面對就面對啊
那也沒有關係啊
就遇到了
好啦 那永關就這樣子啊
這個沒有辦法 偶爾你
這五年的遇到一檔
而且呢
他比較麻煩的是你知道嗎
這個永冠呢
其實你去看第三季財報
其實我們從這邊看得到
這個永冠的第三季財報
他帳上現金有19億
你知道嗎
然後呢
這個他發了15億
他這次實施賣回權
有10亿
那我想说
那你有19亿
也不应该10亿拿不出来吧
结果他真的是10亿不拿出来
就这样子 那没办法
遇到这种就是
就是得认了啦
反正到后来就看债务协账了
那我们当然希望他可以还出来
他可以还出来就
就没事了
那我们下次能遇到KY
就尽量散开
就像滑雪教练会不会
会不会摔倒呢
他还是会摔倒吗
他也不可能一辈子不摔倒
对不对 那就尽量再闪一点嘛
所以我们虽然义高人胆大
也会玩这种可转载
但至少我们会降低我们的风险
不要买太多啦
只能这样子
我只能不要买太多而已啊
当然也绝对不会鼓吹你买
所以各位你看我的文章是
完全没有鼓吹你买的意思哦
完全没鼓吹你买的意思
我是说可转在稳步上涨
不是说叫你买永冠啊
因为呢
他这个2月20号的卖回价是101
那你假如2月20号你没有卖回的话
你没有卖回的话
年后的价格会变很差
所以呢我们是自己卖回了
那也通知
也跟那个持有的人讲说
啊你要记得卖回
這個你當然要記得賣回
因為你不賣回你要再等兩年
你現在賣回是101
那你不賣回你要等兩年
等兩年變成100
這個笨蛋也知道要賣回啊 你懂我意思嗎
你現在可以賣101
那你等兩年你要賣100
翔也知道你要現在賣回啊
那你總不能跟我說
欸小哥不是 我們要等到他拉起來換
那問題是他那時候市值才20幾而已啊
對不對 市值20幾
那個拉起來換的機率比較低嘛
那所以這種當然是
要跟你講說 你要記得賣回
所以發文的初衷是
這個跟投資人講 你要記得賣回
我記得賣回 你有這檔 我記得賣回
不是叫你去買 好不好
我們從頭到尾都沒有我要出貨的意思
都沒有
然後現在網路上說
小哥你是不是叫人家買這一檔
我真的
我就真的不曉得他的大腦在想什麼
我沒有叫你買這一檔啊 好不好
從頭到尾沒有叫你買這一檔
好啦
好 這個是可掌在的狀況啦
反正這個又遇到一件事情了
我們的經驗越來越多
反正我有赚钱有赔钱的经验啦
这个遇到经验
这个你要去找那种永远都赚钱的
那你就去找嘛
因为我不是那种永远都赚钱的
我一定会遇到赔钱的嘛
遇到赔钱我会跟你讲
也不会跟你讲说
我都没有这一档 也没有啦
这我们有 只是没有很多啦
好 感谢希希
我加入超过半年
想说不带单子 说筹码好不好
也不跟筹码好 就叫你买
對啊 這個有時候武藏股要被盜貨
小哥也只會說別追小心受傷
就這樣子
因為我們不想要那個啦
我今天去
今天去那個
今天去錄影
我跟你講 我今天去那個PV錄影
然後呢 錄影的
那錄影有個團隊嘛
他就說 欸 小哥最近有個Case啊
就某一家公司啊
某一家公司
那我就不講哪一家公司
某一家公司想要找财经网红来推荐一下这家公司的股票
嗯?推荐股票?
哦,那我就问他说哪一档
他就告诉我某一档,那我们不能讲出来
哦,告诉我某一档
天哪!
果然像这家公司的样子
我说这种股票
就是我们的世纪投资法里面
哦,世纪投资法,我们有顺应客的
世纪投资法里面秋天的股票
哇塞
現在秋天出貨還會找網紅來配合
配合錄影欸找網紅配合錄影說這家股票有多好拜託欸耶 我哪去录这种我就一四英明回鱼一蛋你知道吗一四英明回鱼一蛋 为什么
因为那种股票 我跟他说
那种股票是纯纯的就秋天嘛
就高档主力卖月线下弯
这种股票我还去推
那我们就不用讲这个世纪投资了
这都秋天股票了
对不对 我说 绝对不可
我说这种业配绝对不要找我
不要找我
这个配一次就死定了
为什么
因为其实你业配股票干嘛
业配股票人家买一次
那个赔钱都找你
赔钱都怪你
所以我们事实上我们不大喜欢
这个很不喜欢
很不喜欢推荐股票这种事情
我只告诉你抽吧怎么样
那你要不要相信呢
例如说我说华泰
抽吧这样子
他赔钱我也跟你讲了好不好
他赔钱也跟你讲
我也沒跟你講說
他賺錢沒有啦 賠錢也跟你講
所以呢 這個狀況怎麼樣呢
我們都會先跟各位講
先跟各位講
所以呢 要不要做 你自己決定
對 期望值高的
要不要做自己決定
這個
大家是龍門 對吧
你拿到兩支K
對不對
然後兩支K當然是ALL IN啊
在你能力所及
能力所及 當然是ALL IN 賭他小嘛
你懂我意思嗎
拿到兩支K 你當然要這樣子 能力所及嘛
當然你能力不及 你就不要ALL IN
能力不及 例如說 你拿到兩支K
那個桌面上有10萬
你沒有能力賠20萬的話 你就
20萬嗎 還是30萬
有人玩30萬
你沒有能力賠30萬 你就不要玩了嘛
你就 說個100塊就好了
A3就ALL IN
最好你A3就all in
所以我說 假如你拿到兩支K對不對
這不all in 才是笨蛋 好不好
當然是all in嘛
啊 all in
我跟你講all in
那你賠錢怪我了
欸欸欸 夠你害的 害我賠錢
我說這個在期望值裡面本來就是要all in啊
你知道嗎 在你能力所及之內
本來就要all in嘛
啊你能力不及 你當然不能all in啊
你懂嗎 你假如有能力賠一千塊
你就是压一千块嘛
有能力赔一万块就压一万块嘛
有能力赔十万块
赔三十万 你就是压十万块嘛你懂吗能力所及 当然要拼嘛那也能力不及不要玩的嘛 你懂嗎 所以沒辦法 就是遇到期望值高的齁
你就是得玩 好不好
就這樣 有人快我眼睛
我們是不希望人家受傷嘛
因為出事了 結果看到
因為我怕有人沒看到新聞
沒看到新聞就去買
我不是鼓勵你買
我不是鼓勵你買 我跟你講說可轉載呢 要記得賣回
但有些人喔 有些人真的是啊
你看到股票 看到股票帶就衝進去
你知道嗎 看到股票就衝進去
那我就沒辦法
所以呢 我們是避免人家受傷
避免人家受傷
好啦 那一開始請各位加這幾個QR Code啦
這個特館粉絲團
Light 光是來 YouTube 跟 IG
那這邊有九蛇優惠券
是PlacePlay的
然後呢這個
呃 光光社團有教育知識喔
YouTube也有教學影片
IG呢 這個會有一些點位圖喔
欸 我在昨天呢
喔 昨天我看一下
哎呀 我昨天有一張圖片
喔 昨天有一張圖片啊
這個我是覺得
我是覺得昨天這個單子
我是覺得有點有點莫名其妙
我來找一下
我來發一下IG好了
因為這個昨天的案例
那我沒有發
因為昨天發了幾檔呢
我沒有再發到這一檔
但昨天這個案例呢真的很特別
很特別喔
這個
來我現在發一下
這個是結算日無敵單
昨天呢
有成交一個結算日無敵單
那给各位看一下
不晓得为什么会有这种无敌单
不晓得为什么会有这种
这么奇怪的这个东西啊
结算是无敌单
啊等等等 完蛋了
我看能不能把它
他這個我看一下我要怎樣把它縮小
我再把它說一下
發給各位看
昨天成交的結算日單子
呃大家覺得這一檔無敵嗎
這成交狀況無敵嗎
好
好啦
來來來
這個我發一篇文發在IG上
給大家研究一下
因為這個蠻特別的
喔
蠻特別的喔
昨天有遇到這個案例
我們現在發在IG給各位看一下
這裡
我来看一下
这笔单
各位看一下哦 这笔单
这笔单真的很特别哦
这笔单是昨天的价差单
他不是價差單
他假如不是價差單
他不會有
他不會有這種點零期喔
這是價差單喔
第一個喔 跟各位講
他是價差單
然後呢 他不是一般單喔
這是同時成交的喔
這是價差單
買了兩口
這個價差單
那各位看一下
這個成交狀況無敵
這個過程是怎樣
所以2月份的緊縮結算在292
那我們講一下
292各位看一下
2月份的緊縮
昨天是292
這裡
第一個結算在292
所以呢我這筆單子
290嘛因為那個
期貨的價格是290
那我是直接買價差單所以我就
賣出一個2月份290
然後買一個3月份的
因為我是買價差單
我買一個付的2.93的價差單
所以我成交一個三月份的287.07
但是我跟各位講
我昨天我可以立馬賣出三月份
因為昨天三月份的單值呢
微買也有290
好再講一次喔
昨天三月份的微買也有290
我大可直接賣290
那我這邊就會賠兩塊
啊我這邊大概可以賺到三塊
賠兩塊賺三塊喔
所以我是一個無敵單
我昨天是一個無敵單喔
因為我可以立馬
立馬怎麼樣 立馬平掉喔
我可以立馬平掉喔 你有看到
我可以立馬平掉 但我選擇不平
我沒有平 為什麼 因為我覺得他
漲停板他應該會開高啊
結果今天一開板真的是開高啦 我開板就賣掉了
這個 我一開板就賣掉了
所以 各位你覺得這是不是一個無敵單
他真的是個無敵單
啊真的是個無敵單
好這是學員通知我的
不是我發現的
學員通知我的
我教學員套利
學員跟我講
欸小哥有這筆單子
你要不要吃
我說當然要吃啊
這種送錢的還不吃
啊
所以竹竹同學
竹同學
下次來桃園我請你吃一頓啊
感謝你推薦我這個價差單
無敵價差單啊
各位讲这是无敌驾沙单
我可以立马
我各位你看这笔单我可以立马卖290了
卖290是赚3块
那我这边是赔2块
3块赔2块
朱同学
yo yo yo yo yo
下下下下次我请你
哈哈
朱同学专门玩套利
玩套利
玩得很厉害
玩得很厉害盘中来通知我这种好康的
喔 那他吃一吃來問我 小哥這一檔
我說這個無敵勒
無敵當然是趕快吃下去
好不好 趕快吃
欸 這個我覺得蠻好的
教學相長 好不好
我們是平常教人家怎麼套利
人家盤中還提醒我們來套利 你知道嗎
我的
盤中提醒套利
各位你看一下
我選擇
我昨天評調是可以賺4000啦
但我覺得今天評調
喔 所以我這邊是
呃
290我是賠了
這邊賠了2塊嘛我這邊賠4千那我今天開盤賣盤賣305我賣低盤我賣低盤跟各位講老實跟各位講
我賣低盤
我不是賣漲停的沒那麼厲害
我也不曉得今天會漲停
但是我賣低盤
因為奇卧
我覺得低盤賣出的不錯了
因為低盤在開高啊
我們來看一下低盤多少
有沒有
來看低盤
這裡
又賣到第一盤
後面再買回來
哈哈哈哈
因為做個當充嘛
所以這很好啊 教學相長嘛 對不對
我們平常教人家怎麼套
哇塞 這同學已經進化到
連價差單都還套
進化到價差單都還套
哇 非常好
好啦 聽不懂就算了
聽懂了 大家都沒飯吃了
沒飯吃了
好 我只是告訴你說 我很開心
那個 這叫教學相長 好不好
我們平常呢 就是與人為善嘛
對不對 認真教學嘛
教你有用的東西嘛 好不好
人家豬同學 這個
靠套利 靠那個
套利交易 可以養家活口
然後可以賺的比他太太還多
比他太太還多
所以每次去台東玩
他每次都請我吃飯
有點不好意思
每次去都每次請我吃
然後他說 哎小哥
每次都給你請
小哥不要客氣啦
你教我套利我都已經賺那麼多了
哇
你聽聽也蠻感動的啦
所以呢
這個就是一個善的循環
我們講這個善的循環
好
好啦
來 那今天請各位加這個LINE的社群
LINE的社群
LINE的社群呢 這個密碼呢
這個四個八
四個八
四個八啊 各位加一下
套利克 哪也可以選
套利克就有教了啦
這套利克也教了
昨天還有很多可以套啊
喔 昨天真的超多的
昨天超多可以套
喔 昨天滿天都金條啊
麻天全金條
好 然後呢 欸 講一下
这工商一下我们有四季投资法
这是新的跟PP合作的课程
支导
那这个股票有四季啊春根夏云秋作东厂那教你这个做這些交易那我們這次哇 可轉載我可以多錄一段可轉載 踩雷
遇到踩雷 春耕踩到雷
下次跟你講說怎麼樣不會踩
其實我們在裡面就有教各位不會踩雷
我們也不希望你踩雷啊
只是我們就比較玩刺激一點啦
好 那是一投資法呢
這個 叫你不再盲目進場
資金效率最大化
可複製贏家的邏輯啦
有25年的
實證的操作流程
那購客會想
我們這個
募資上限當月到2022年12月
每月會一支四季實戰觀測影片
就是我們會把這四季的股票
那四季股票我們就用那個
那個
嗯 舉例來說我們用當成季的參數
啊這參數我就最近我可能在
呃 我們有個初步的參數啦
好 那我們現在也可以給各位看
好
來 給各位看
这个
春夏秋冬的股票
这里有春天股票
这些春天啊
春天的殖利率都还不错
那春天殖利率你可能还要再去查一下
看他的殖利率
看他的今年有没有机会好
那今年的殖利率有没有机会好
我们最近在PP有一段这个
有一段文章啦
这边有
高殖利率股票研究在这里
那我們有一個直立率經典版
各位呢你就把它下載
下載喔 這邊就直立經典版
它有近三年股利
平均發行率前三季獲利除股價
那這幾個呢是
未來有機會
這個配發高股息的
你可以再看看
它的近三年股利率平均發行率
然後去猜一下
它今年有沒有可能是高股息
那這邊喔 這邊我看一下
喔 這邊 喔 這
這個經濟喔 經濟那是才88塊
這前三季 貨利儲股價4.5
不過他的股地發揮率蠻高的
那今年 第四季看起來應該也不會多爛了
那各位 反正你可以找這種
呃 配息穩定的
配息穩定 經濟還算蠻穩定的
所以我覺得經濟應該算還不錯啦
最近也開始走多頭了齁
這個開布林這個主力買
開布林主力買 我覺得
我覺得後面是有機會的
那各位你看他殖利率5.68
然後他的近世紀5.6
呃你再看他過往的這個這個配息的状况哦我看一下哦在过往的这个配平均发放率是80%啦
所以呢呃假设5.6
这个第四季还不知道吗
哦那假设
我们用5.6然后配80%去算的话
其实值率也还ok
还还不错啊
这个表呢在这边就可以下载了啊
在這篇文章裡面
好啦
那這個後來我們就會跟各位講
呃
之後每個月呢會有一段文章
我們就來看春天的股票哪些
夏天的股票哪些
來來來各位看一下
最近夏天的股票有誰呢
齁
各位看一下最近夏天股票
很熱的喔
哇塞這邊一堆夏天的
德宏
齁夏天的
齁
望宏
齁夏天的
森達科
夏天的
齁這都很下喔
好不好
這個
不要亂空
再跟我講不要亂空啊
好不好
夏天的不要亂空
不要亂空
好不好
好
那各位呢
你看一下這個秋天股票
這夏天了
來看秋天
那秋天股票呢
就是
哎
比較危險一點
好
我們來看一下
這邊秋天股票
秋天股票呢
哎
看起來月星有點走平
然後主力賣出的
那這有點秋天的感覺
好不好
秋天股票
各位看一下
这有点秋天
有点要步入秋天的感觉
那四季呢就是教你看这种股票了
这个你看有点秋天
你各位看夏天跟秋天就不一样
秋天就有点做头的疑虑
那月星有点下弯
这比较危险的
那这个教你看春夏秋冬
你看冬天股票来
也不看冬天
冬天股票
你看哇开始往下走了
太緊了
你開始往下走主力賣
開始往下走主力賣
這邊啊 你看這邊有很多
開始往下走
所以呢 這邊會幫你找出春夏秋冬的股票
還有這個立夏
立夏 立夏
今天的這個
看起來 今天我們立夏
來來來來 看今天立夏的股票
今天最強的陽明光
喔 這個有點要翹起來的感覺喔
但不曉得會不會真的往上走啦
不確定
所以呢 這邊有些
有几个都是刚刚翘起来
刚刚翘起来的样子
刚刚翘起来
所以呢这边会教你那个
春夏秋冬怎么弄
怎么找
然后呢教你怎么分辨
好
那后面呢有那个我跟子涓谷
也还有轻影呢
的这个
这个录影的影片啊
就是你想看一般方案也可以
你想要再看我们三个人
这个讲课程的状况也可以
就是加持發行限定
這看你都看你要喜歡就可以
那這個我們還會
呃有直播 QA 還有正交易筆記本
訂閱一個月
所以其實蠻花賺的啦
這邊
各位有需要的購買
那目前有那種
呃最最優惠價格
那已經在社群裡面
各位你可以加入社群裡面找一下
啊好啦那
呃
跟各位講我們
居然是小編
小編呢他早就換大刀貼了
所以假如有這個
这个距离的这个大陆月的小编
失去你的话那肯定是诈骗了
肯定是诈骗了
所以各位这个
你看一下我封锁这么多距离
好啦那直播注意事项
请将一通话词调到最高
这几个自己看一下
来看上周中奖名单
各位小哥学习对于实际调改
恭喜你中奖了
再失去我们那个
你的
你的这个
全家店名还有电话
好 田小哥
這個步步大發財
每日聽PP內容豐富又實在
就算當天沒空了解盤子看小哥PP掌握盤子不會理
小哥不能退休啊
好 謝謝 感謝
好 那這是學員的戰機啊
各位看一下學員戰機
學員戰機在這裡
好 那1 2月份
1 2月份股票起往
哎呦 我1 2月份還沒貼
12月份我12月份的股票我把
買進成本為0的過濾掉
12月份做的還不錯啊目前
呃這個獲利有到600多然後我的買賣金額呢
已經來到了
40億
快40億了嘛
不過你看一下這每個都是
20億
喔每個20億
這個我買賣的金額
是永貫
的
可轉載的4倍
好不好
4倍
好啦
但是
就這樣
這個泰式不還我也沒辦法啊那我們這個買賣金額這麼大其實還可以再還可以再退佣這個手續還可以打折 還沒加進來
所以加進來呢
加進來 假如有冠出事可能
有些要拿去賠用冠了
那沒辦法啦 遇到就遇到
那我在抗新金賺的獲利呢
在去年
去年到目前的獲利齁
大概
有到
我算一下 應該是
八九百啦
就去年
這個新金賺
就是我們
我們做那個
就
就 反正貨利八九百
那這個呢
呃 彎永鑽出自
要拿一部分來賠啦
就這樣子啦 沒辦法啦
遇到就遇到
遇到就遇到 遇到 遇到 遇到 賠就賠
好
賠就賠
來
好 來來看一下這大盤走勢
這樣子喔
各位
呃這個是這個是那個結算在講的
那我們講一下我們今天的主題啦
我們今天主題這個
來講一下
等一下還是要講一下主題
我們一開始就講一下
現在我們還在講
這個
真大戶手握清單喔
各位呢有幾個方法可以找
第一個方法呢
我們可以直接找怎麼樣
例如說我們現在呢
各位啊這個你找
你找怎麼樣
你找不喜歡等待的
沒關係啊 直接找夏天了啦
我們直接找夏天的股票
好不好 不喜歡等待的 直接找夏天股票
然後直接買這種主力有在買的
主力有在買的
凱基金 哇 主力有在買
波羅威這個
這個不要買了 這個短線長太多了
長太多的你可以避開啦
或者是鋼翹的 這也不錯
主力有在買 開布林的
直接找夏天主力有在買的
啊這個就是有在動的
找夏天主力有在買就是有在動的股票
有在動的股票
經濟元大北投在出貨
看一下
還好啦26張好不好買那麼多
各位你看一下買那麼多欸各位
不要害怕好不好
欸元大北投這條線
才稍微挖一點點有在出貨
小哥有帶出貨啦
欸欸欸欸
這把他幣啦
這把他幣
呵呵有沒有看到
這沒辦法幣啦這個賣的量這賣的量還不夠多啦還不夠多還希望越漲賣越多啦呵呵因為他在這裡有買嘛
所以今天調節一點我覺得
情有可言好不好
情有可言
好
就這樣喔
這個
呃
欸 待會兒來
所以
真大貨
我教各位就是
你去找
像這個凱基金
例如說你找這個主食的
找主食這幾張
主食很大的
那這種都是有人在囤貨
各位看一下
你看凱基金
你看這主力
這有沒有人在囤貨
這肯定有啊
好不好 有沒有在囤
你一定有
好不好
一定有在囤
各位你看一下
大摩囤成這樣
然後呢
這個賣美商高盛買成這樣
摩根大通買成這樣
凱基台北買成這樣
這個凱基台北肯定不是
那個隔日沖的凱基台北嘛
對不對
所以呢你可以從這樣找
那夏天的股票
你就可以找到好幾檔
這邊很多檔
你看中工也在裡面
中工我有
我有
這個有在裡面
這邊很多啊
光寶科
光寶科也不錯
對不對
主力買上回俏
這個楊老師
這個昨天
今天
眼書有提到的
這不錯啊
所以你看連帽
連帽這個籌碼不錯
所以你可以從這邊找籌碼不錯的
他已經在動了
這叫夏天的股票
夏天的股票
參數呢我們在PPE裡面有講的
你可以去PPE裡面看
教你怎麼找夏天股票
你要玩
你要玩價差的
找夏天股票
你看今天
這個夏天股票
我今天一堆紅K
對不對
找夏天股票
夏天股票
好啦
參數我們都寫APP了
各位可以去看一下
好 來
接下來我們看一下
這個
這個是第一個就是你可以找夏天股票
然後呢去找
那第二個呢
你也可以從分點調查局的
神秘券商
神秘券商裡面
喔 隨便在裡面分點異常
喔 那你可以找 例如說我們找這10天然後看一看 欸 哪些股票有人在吃啊喔 這個和奇啊 菠蘿菠蘿威啊這個有在吃喔但是有些股票他假如沒有噴出去
有可能就低檔承接
那這個你買起來
他就不是
夏天那可能就是春天
好啊春天股票就是要等待啦
所以春天股票你要等的時候
你就好搭配高值利率啦
那假如沒有高值率
那就不要看了
就不要看了
PPE
PPE你可以看常見QA啦
我們的參數
參數我記得我放上去
沒有的話你再跟我講我再放
我再放去
好
那參數我們都放了
沒有放我到底再放
好這個是那個
那個
這個
有在買可是像這種你買起來就
敢有敢有對不對
這種陷阱就看起來
這種就是
比較春天一點的
所以呢
這邊是有在買
這有在動的
有在買
啊有沒有在動你可以看陷阱就知道
看線你就知道
這個都是有人有在
D檔收的
每個塊有人在收
所以各位你可以看看這些籌碼
這邊是有人在收的
那你也可以從什麼地方看呢
你也可以從全證籌碼來看
那全證籌碼在這邊
來教各位看
全證籌碼各位從全方位裡面可以看到
全方位喔
全方位我教各位找
你去裡面找大戶收命
找大戶收命
然後呢你可以找
例如說這兩天
這兩天全鎮
在買的有誰
哇雙紅
雙紅
台中哥大買
有沒有
來
創意
創意國票
國票就算了
國標隔日沖嘛
黃永昌鋼山也還好
因為這個比較短
這個是不是波段呢
我們會有經驗
反正你點進來看就知道波段了
這個就是短線嘛
所以這個就還好
這個就不用跟
那你要找的是
它可能它是波段的
波段才跟
來看智邦
智邦
所以影片2點41分開始有4G產數
待會我再放在場面QA
啊
這字幫就這樣
啊這個群衣總理
啊字幫用買
你可以從這裡找到
這個全證有在買
你可以把時間再拉上來
例如說你沒有20天
因為20天就看到我們講華泰了
華泰 華套上台中
喔
華套上台中欸
還有一個厲害分點叫富邦工藝
富邦工藝我記得還蠻厲害的
目前還是賠錢
目前賠錢喔
所以呢
可以用這個
這個來找
哦
哦那是带宽20%是用阻力买上轨开步你们
哎比较差一点啊比较差一点
哦没有那么漂亮
哦好啦所以这个这边呢你可以去找到
呃有些特殊的分点有在买
有在买全镇的哦有在买全镇的哦从这里面找
哦那你找看看
有没有哪个
有没有哪个比较特殊的分点在买哦各位可以从里面找看看
好
來 四季投資法不需要搭配軟體
課程會附上你會講一個方式
呃 這個四季投資法
這個有軟體來
來來抓股票很好
你假如沒有軟體抓股票
你也可以自己
自己來分辨
好嗎
好啦
來以上就是這個我們的今天的
今天的這個大戶掃握清單
哦 那最近有四季投資法
各位有興趣你可以在說明欄連結上面有
好 最後呢
新增強檔我們有
全方位監控跟當成器軟體在這裡
五九折
這邊有五九折
有需要可以買
然後呢可轉載入門基礎班
3月13號
哇 這是
還特別可以講一下
這勇冠踩雷的過程啊
踩雷過程
其實
我們就是很多檔都會做啦
所以有時候遇到踩雷
感覺好像也
也有可能會遇到
沒有辦法
那直播優惠呢
這邊呢 重碼可以先
學生小哥交易筆記本在這邊
有興趣的歡迎訂閱啦
那這次
頁月力蠻高的喔
那這次有需要的
你買試技課也會送你這個
交易筆記本的訂閱
那你假如是老客戶的話他會幫你延長
所以你就可以掃繳一個月的錢
掃繳一個月
好那以上呢是今天的直播各位有興趣歡迎按讚訂閱喔 留言關心的抽景品 欸我們今天有
欸我去小燕心夾到的
快龍
有需要的你可以留言
欸不錯喔
現場QA時間
那現在可以讓各位發問啊
喔 那我們今天這個
呃 大部分都有
呃 各位有問題的都有回答到
喔 抽一個NP 關鍵了
喔 有有有 好
想要的歡迎 上面留言
欸 最後
最後來
那個有獎真打一下
可轉載入門基礎灣 台中廠幾號上二
台中廠幾號上二
這個歡迎
喔 幫你各位留言一下
啊
好
抽藥
23跟18號
好 23跟18號啦
好啦
這個
以上是今天的直播
啊各位有什麼問題呢可以在上面問啊
這個是我
我去那個瑞士玩的照片
好
歡迎各位問問題啊
最近呢
哇很多股票很強喔
尤其這種夏季的股票
夏季籌碼好盤中有攻擊量的喔
你都要注意啊
現在走勢變動有創高的
有創高的可能今天都還蠻強的喔
四季課程永久觀看沒有錯喔
永久觀看沒有錯
只要PP不倒
應該是不大會倒啦
不倒的都是永久觀看6139亞像抽包好嗎不好這個看起來是秋天的股票好不好主力賣
然後月線下彎秋天股票
北基
北基呢
他有兩檔可轉債了
然後
股價有點弱啊
通常這種
可轉債其實
腳股價到一二十塊的
你都要小心一點啊
都要小心一點
北基應該還好啦
我是覺得應該還好
我是覺得應該還好啊
哦富邦七點最近買很多
好
6488入東了嗎
看一下
嗯
應該也還好
哦
昨天熱鬥選擇犬喔
這個昨天熱鬥選擇犬喔
那去到我們昨天PB有回答了
PB有回答了
好
來 大家看 怎麼看記憶體啊
記憶體 最近的
這個記憶體我覺得這個老大好像比較弱一點
藍雅科啊跟那個
華旺店喔 我覺得比較沒那麼強
最近最強的是個變態的旺宏
旺宏最超強
超強喔 但旺宏他的強是有節奏的啦
就是一紅一黑 一紅一黑
他最近超強 但是他的籌碼就是一紅一黑啦
所以各位你望虹你要上車的話你要
這種是夏天的股票嘛對不對
但是你要上車你要遵守他的節奏
如果你看他的節奏他是有節奏的喔
黑紅黑紅黑紅喔
有節奏的喔
有節奏的
這個
這個各位看籌碼很爛的
籌碼不好
反彈的籌碼不好
要變成那個
要變成夏天的話
因為這有點秋天味道嘛對不對
要變成夏天呢就是只有創高
才有機會又變成夏天
那全新為什麼躲過注意
全新這邊有點麻煩喔
因為你看一下他的第六款
他第六款是
呃主要是元大證券成交買進金額達1億元以上
這什麼鬼啊
有沒有看到
要符合這條件,元大證券才買超過1億
元大腳沒買超過1億,就沒啊
所以要一個元大
元大的要施心瘋的大買,才會超過1億所以這個,他的第六款難以估計比較不好算比較不好算
信心紅顏低買高顏
這個有可能
有兩種可能
一個是庫藏股時是有
有發生過
所以呢你要看一下
有沒有庫藏股
因為這個
這是我們用很長一段時間的
這個籌碼
你要看有沒有庫藏股實施啊
或是低買高賣啊
可以看一段時間
這個庫藏股實施
那金居呢
金居
這個蠻強的
今天出關
那金居就是有個麻煩啊
但這個麻煩我不曉得會不會變成
因為金居也有機會創高
但會不會變成
波羅威
因為最近呢
最近波羅威也有麻煩對不對
他最近 欸 波羅威投胎換骨了
喔 他現在不怕處置了 你知道嗎 以前他怕得要死
哇 現在波羅威不怕了 現在
這怕欸齁
最近處置骨喔
這個很兇悍啊 各位看到
聯亞長這樣 波羅威長這樣
喔 最近處置骨有夠兇的喔 五清雲長這樣
各位看一下 最近處置骨很兇喔
好 處置股呢 到了3月份喔
每個發了瘋的兇啊
喔
對 就這樣
好
好 所以
以上呢 是
這個
跟各位分享的喔
那各位呢
你
喜歡找
刺激的
歡迎來找
這個
夏天的股票
那怎麼找夏天股票呢
呃 歡迎來上
來上
這堂課就教你怎麼找
夏天的股票
好啦
以上呢是這個
跟各位講的
西藤投資本那個優惠連結會在
放在社群裡
各位就社群社群4個8
歡迎各位講
好
那以上是今天的直播啦
我要準備去
準備去
這個
錄PP啦
好
那我們今天呢就講到這裡
要跟各位說再見啦
各位掰掰
再見再見
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕